after you made your first feature film
you stopped making movies yes I did
I said I would never make another
feature film again I just was trying I
couldn't do it because I didn't know
what why this one filmmaker can make a
film that wasn't the best film ever made
and continue to make progress and then I
can make a film and nobody care I didn't
understand that but I also at the time
didn't understand the business you know
in the business of visibility the
business of associations of knowing
people you know I didn't have any event
I was just just one this young man
creating these films and my own lab and
not that many resources to get him out
into the world so I had a very small
approach and I just knew that I was like
it's too hard I'm not gonna do it so I
just decided to just become a playwright
in New York as opposed to keep thinking
a film so you still wanted to be
creative I wanted to create but I wanted
to do it in a place that was a little
more safe a place where I could like
have regular things like afford a cup of
coffee I wanted to be able to have my
own apartment and you know be happy and
have clothes and shoes that didn't have
holes in them so I was like it's not
gonna happen for him in the feature film
world how long did you need away from
all that before you said okay I'm ready
to kind of like dip my toe back in it's
about six years there's about six years
I started to see a lot of people making
the short form digital content online
that was really really good and I caught
up with a friend and also a writer a
director named Raven drummer out of
Atlanta and I said hey like have this
really good idea for this series about
these two writers who come together to
make a project there's really something
else
below the surface would you be
interested and she said sure so she put
up 2,500 I put her 25 and then another
friend put up 25 and we made eight
episode web series on $7,500
what was the web series about yeah it
was Brooklyn blue sky and it was about
blue and Skylar's journey towards
in a pilot for a Netflix and chill
competition yes yes so art imitating
life is fine imitating life anybody
since because she was a woman and I you
know I'm a man and we were trying to
make this project but we had something
underneath it I don't want to tell the
story okay that's all about something
underneath it that needed to be further
explored and so we were able to put it
in that landscape and you know
thankfully everything went really really
go better than we ever expected with
that so you almost didn't come to LA you
would have still been in New York doing
plays which doesn't sound like a bad
life yeah I had no plans to move to LA I
was like no not for me I'm gonna make it
in New York and I'll never have to move
to LA but about a year ago a little over
a year ago something something in me
just started beating this is in order
for your career to go to the next level
you have to go to LA and I had a lot of
fear because I'd already have a
beautiful life set up for me in Brooklyn
and I just I bought a one-way ticket for
January 15th of 2019 and I came here and
I've been here ever since and creating
content and things have been happening
you go by your intuition it sounds like
press that's wrong let a guy by to say
yes and to say no it's by that internal
it's a muscle that you use and the more
that you engage and use that muscle of
listening to that internal dialogue the
easier it gets right so now even with
hiring like a sound person like I know
like this is person I should hire not
that person
it's just something internal and I'm
still make some bad decisions I'm not
saying now everything I do is great
never decision I make is the bomb but
I'm a lot more aware of why making
decisions I know what I'm connecting to
in a person whether it's generosity or a
creative creative curiosity I know what
it is that I'm connecting with someone
on so it's making me a lot more
purposeful and it's making my work a lot
better which do you have a harder time
with saying yes or no nowadays is harder
I have a much
I'm saying yes because now I'm being
presented with options where before
everything that I was doing was just me
internally doing it but now you have all
you have a feature film opportunity here
you have this opportunity to direct
television here you have this
opportunity here so now I have three
different things to look at in order to
make that decision and all things within
context makes sense but now I'm going
what is what am i truly aligned to doing
and it's hard to look at a network and
say no thank you I don't wanna direct
your television show nothing I don't
want to direct your television show but
I'm more in line right now to do a
feature film so it's harder to make
those decisions and you know what you're
leaving on the table because I could
make money doing that but I'm so but I'm
God is so fiercely by my purpose that's
the thing that I move and I only work
with people only work with companies
that I know are directly aligned with my
purpose and where I'm headed do you have
someone from your past a family member a
mentor somebody that you really trust do
I do probably the closest person to me
is my sister she's been really a part of
my journey from the very beginning she's
read everything that I've done and she's
seen everything she's been at all of my
readings she's been everywhere and she
knows who I am today as opposed to who I
was yesterday and so she makes sure that
I continue to make decisions that I
don't fall into a lot of those old
pitfalls of not being able to say no or
moving faster than what I need to for
the sake of getting it done as opposed
to getting it done correctly and so
she's able to advise me in a way that is
that makes a lot of sense and we laugh
and we enjoyed the process when we do it
and she's back home yes she's an
Arkansas yeah it's a lot of phone calls
yeah a lot far everyday oh wow every day
and then you had to reevaluate why you
wanted to be in this industry
you saw that it wasn't for the reasons
you thought or sorry I don't mean yeah
that's a hundred percent correct I
wanted to get into the industry because
I wanted to tell stories about myself to
be quite honest with you and so if you
look at them out of my earlier
it always is like a direct reflection of
me
but as I've continued to like grow as an
artist I realize the greatest power that
I have is still in my power and agencies
are telling other marginalized stories
and so I've been a person has been
fighting a good fight when I was a kid
when I was in college and now I'm
actively doing that as a storyteller so
I'm putting my lenses on stories that
don't necessarily reflect me
although the journeys of these
characters do reflect me right so like
for instance King Esther is about a
trans woman in New Orleans but I'm not a
trans woman I'm not from New Orleans but
the human connection of needing to be
seen against all odds that's what we
connect and so now I'm seeing everything
doesn't have to be a reflection of
myself and so now I'm making better
stories I'm telling more rich characters
more flawed characters because it's not
any reflections of myself and it sounds
like to that what we talked about
earlier that character wanting to sort
of validate within themselves and not
have it what the world's telling them
that they are absolutely history is to
get to that emotional to get to that
emotional truth and that's what I'm able
to tell now now that I know what my
emotional truth is and that is I am a
storyteller and I am worthy of telling
stories that I don't necessarily own and
now I'm actively doing that and I love
it do you feel these stories come from
some other place yes they all come from
me like I don't think there's a
character that I've written that didn't
reflect me in some way shape form or
fashion even the ones that I really
don't like I mean I have to admit there
are parts of myself that I just don't
celebrate you know I don't like I know
they need to change whether that is
again my ability to people please I used
to be a people pleaser and to my own
detriment I'm still actively working on
that that belief in self that I'm
capable of doing things that necessarily
haven't been designed for me I'm having
to work on that
working on my graciousness being more
gracious more grateful more humble each
and every day for what I've been given
and those people that I'm surrounded by
so as I get better and as I continue to
get to my emotional truth and explore it
I'm doing that better with characters
and now I'm telling better stories and I
think going back to that talk that you
did in Brooklyn you had said that your
you had to re-evaluate why you wanted to
be in this industry
and maybe before it was being famous and
I think that's a very common thing for a
lot of people why they get started
especially when they're younger and then
it came down to just telling stories
mm-hmm yeah what happened there how did
you how did you cuz I think it's some
people I know somebody came at me once
they said well how dare you say that but
that's a common thing for a lot of
people they want to be famous
especially in this this social media age
absolutely because even when I was
growing up Fame afforded you a certain
level of privilege that I wanted to have
I wanted to be able to travel I wanted
to have money I wanted to be able to buy
things and so I knew being a young black
poor boy from Arkansas the only way I
was going to get there you got to become
famous people all have to know who you
are and I think there are a number of
things that really like defined and
refined what that experience was because
it's still very much possibility that I
could become a household name and a star
but that it's not how I identify myself
you have to get away from that and an
ego and get to the intrinsic nature of
who you are and I realized that I was
just
he brought here to create and tell
stories right and the manner in which I
do that and how I do that is the
definition of Who I am and so when I
started to see that and not have a
connection to physical tangible things
like a city or a house or an apartment
or a couch version old pumas that needed
to be thrown out
I can then approach my work so
differently there's a freedom that I
have now there's a there's an approach
that I have now where I'm not pressed
I'm not pressed to make this decision or
that decision because I know what's for
me is truly is for
so that was really the difference and
now that I've really been able to
evaluate that I continue to evaluate
that right and make sure that everything
that I'm doing it's just the line with
the purity of telling stories and making
sure that I'm doing them in the most
authentic way possible did you use to
have someone tell you stories when you
were kid no I just tell the stories
stories and I just love to entertain
people through with stories even when
like I met dinners with friends and I'm
telling a story it's always this this
bigness to the way that I do it but
growing up no my mom and my stepfather
were very very very religious very
religious people so we were at Bible
class all the time pretty much like six
days a week we were there doing that so
I didn't really have time to they didn't
have time to tell a whole lot of stories
I mostly told stories to others well
there's a lot of with parables and I
mean there's a lot of storytelling
within the Bible there is a lot of
storytelling within the Bible has some
of the greatest stories I mean a lot of
my work is derive still from this the
story of Adam and Eve it's an allegory
that continues to come up almost all of
my work
you